sono stato io
benvenuti sono stati oggi a grandissima
richiesta novisti questi grumi dovremmo
scappare dalla prigione con tantissime
altre cose paurose come potete vedere
c'è già un una sorta di poliziotto
guardiano zombie da cui dobbiamo
scappare da quindi dobbiamo farci
prendere sarà super divertente ma
soprattutto anche paurosa poi lasciate
vediamo gli altri 10 mila mi piace fare
un'altra tutti subito presi pop corn e
iniziamo subito lei vediamo cosa ci
aspetta ci sono birichini
e c'era un tram è servita le matin la
nostra cella questa attenta ci fanno gli
scarafaggi a dare le carte
che prima e proprio paolo forse dobbiamo
cercare qualcosa capace di schiacciare
qua abbiamo presentato prima fare anche
per gli offre una porta non si apre ora
vi sono i mostri potrebbero saltare
fuori all'improvviso sono troppo bravo
ormai con lo skate chrome non miss
fratello quasi più vedremo quante volte
a fare cell era vitale
meglio
[Musica]
e cosa più attento e vita questi che
questa musica è molto inquietante
ma ci sono delle punte poi per terra c'è
scritto allontanati da qua e là della
zona ma bisogna buttarsi aspettami
allora c'è una cosa
la bara aiuto io mi spavento molto
facilmente roba che ero come avete
potuto vedere dove sei tu mi arrivano
per l'ironia sentito urlare
io ho preso chi nel mio preso il
poliziotto mi ha presentato al lido
diventa venendo scappare
ovviamente però
tu dove sei tutti dietro ho ricominciato
perché solo dito lettera
ai corinti di strano che si gioca
macchine aiuto credo che
ho fatto prendere io sono andato avanti
ma è difficilissimo come faccio a
scappar di i sogni bisogna andare su per
difetto di cordì corsa gli
esami subito sotto
sopra corri corri corri corri no vabbè
io l'anti ambire laterali sono rivelati
all'altra
no brava subito sul posto per la
sinistra dovesse mai
ricco di prova ok dove dovremo dare
spieghiamo ci sbrighiamo se prima si
arrivi a
pensavo di averle già aperte dove quel
mostro ma stai tu ok mai magari sarà
stato il lato
perché praticamente qui c'è un tempo poi
dopo queste cade e si è basata su questi
cooper vitali avete lasciato percorso
via
ok è no
ok ok non premere la leva proviamo a
tinta ma che si muovono dover evitare di
sbriciolato
a sinistra noi siamo noi fretta non ci
credo ce l'ho fatta ce l'abbiamo fatta
bisogna sfracellare all'ultimo a e viva
che non abbiamo ok italia momento
bisognava tagliare l'elettricità prima
si fa dobbiamo l'elettricità da qui
penso mi sono fidato produzione dobbiamo
solo stare attenti ok poi atteso letta
che smetta di usare l'elettricità
sei già arrivato scusi
se non la vendita ma ok ok che ci sono
sicuro dai sbrigati
eccomi dove sei se questo lavandino che
magari meglio
allora che dice non avvicinarsi troppo
inferme
infermiere
ciascuno
che cos'è
bisogna avvicinarsi diano zombie
già
[Musica]
perché non bisogna avvicinarsi troppo
bisogna andare piano
ok
insomma sono passato
aiuto dai dai
prometto niente piano piano si tenta di
piero chiara io sono già fatto il
concerto si faccia sei quasi eccoti
bravo allora questo non ti piacerebbe
che queste ci sono delle
spiagge calci comporterà deve fare
qualcosa qui mi sa di no bene bisogna
correre allora via a tema
b no no
no ci sono quasi
mai vari brani c'è scritto non entrare
quasi figurati se non a nel fermo che
dice di
arrampicarsi sulla torta
dove la corda non era guardavano
della corda e vizio doveva gare alla
fine della stanza si però non ho capito
come fare a saltarci sopra no stavolta
proprio passare da un altro porto anche
tu sei stato offerto per riesco non
farmi vedere
fa paura questo arriva molta paura
no sembra peggio di grendi questa
guardia
entro questo è il seguente
nota sull'accordo possono bloccata e
come è stata battuta come fatto ai fatti
non ci riesco a passare forse ti devi
solo muovere un po
[Applauso]
contro fatah deve saltare in continuo
non è così o meno possibilità
di caduta non ha fatto cadere non
riscontrare qua dentro
si va da un portavoce non l'avete visto
quattro morti 500 sibilano volta e
allora dice che cuoce un pericolo ci
sono degli zombie li attento e degli
scheletri mi sembra che siamo già ad
halloween
attento se cadiamo dalla sotto credo che
sarà una buca mina legge di buon vento
che ci spinge forse perché bisogna
saltare
bene sarà ancora più difficile e allora
chi và và attivo il primo
turno ce l'ha fatta ok
dai cui parla bene dove andare progetto
for the ok dai bar e attenta siamo
riusciti ad uscire da qui in qua o forse
siamo vicini alla fine mi sembra troppo
manine ne avevo ma non c'è niente in
diamo quindi forse questa porta
delle lavatrici si diceva in caste un
test che di uno scheletro dentro c'è
scritto clicca qua
che è successo
il sarcofago come si chiama
dobbiamo prendere il piccone preso un
piccone credo si allora io presenta sco
dove dobbiamo usarli dobbiamo scavare
quarda ok ho preso anche il casco è ok
il piccone abbiamo aperto qua quindi
stiamo scavando un tunnel sotterraneo
per scappare non so quale devo cliccare
tra questi sicuramente uno di questi è
una trafficata trovato
sapeva che c'è una trappola aspetta ma
che è successo ha scavato un altra parte
ma non so quale sia quella giusta può
proviamo andare ma ha dovuto guardium
dischi prum complicate dobbiamo fare
tutto il rabbi vinto io avrei detto
allora non era quello davanti forse
questo
[Applauso]
no non credo
ma non c'è nessuno più quindi ecco devo
continuare a scavare vede
non preveda xe no o no un vicolo cieco
riusciremo a uscire da qui entriamo
ebrea minecraft che stiamo scavando
dappertutto però forse non è questo
allora qui non ho capito e funziona tipo
campo minato quindi non dobbiamo
prendere la ics ma smontare tutto quanto
o poi uscirà fuori la strada giusta no
cornuto fateci uscire queste peep rom e
un labirinto e ma tu dove sei non
perdiamoci io sono stato sul nostra
parte no ora ci ritroviamo più cannes è
sparito no io sono qui questo sto
sviluppando tutto allora ci sono qui in
mezzo l'ex
forse troviamo per parte per me lei no
non penso
tutto un vicolo cieco e quindi adesso ci
incontreremo prima o poi dipende da
dover dei pini ma perché non ti trovo
più peggio per te
ho trovato la scelta guarda
come continuare a scavare allora no non
so più dove sto andando troppo allora io
sto io sto scavando vicino ai lati del
muro così magari se c'è un'uscita la
troviamo quasi un altro buco ma forse ed
entrato
aspettiamo tutto sono qui ho più
proviamo a distruggere tutto
evidente calo dei
timori deciderlo perito dice vai
non mi ha detto
no no
no b brevi
[Musica]
e cercando di
noi appreso farcela purtroppo vedrà
minuto dopo progetto noi sa se mi piace
adesso passato per portargli fortuna
forse ce la farò nel frattempo vi faccio
vedere la stanza in cui sono e
stranissima c'è scritto trova
l'interruttore adoro perché una torta di
skype room
indovinelli in cui devo trovare qualcosa
quindi nel frattempo che vitale continua
a morire io cornini insomma riccardi
interruttore
allora
giovane nuoto
che succede se abbiamo un rigore invece
una telecamera vista che ci sta spiando
la guardiamo chiuri di rum dice la
camera di stramare allora c'è scritto
scegli
attentamente scegli saggiamente colori
ma gli interruttori cosa succede se
proviamo l'interruttore sbagliato
provvederà inizio proprio a premere il
primo
non era il primo è no dissi serviti no
io vado col terzo
non ci credo hai fatto sfracellare
provoco il secondo lo faccio da lontano
a
fare i pulsanti mancano per ultimo
paura
manca questo
sono molto bravo
no no non sette passi ok qua ci sono
altre celle
dice trova l'accordo per aprire la porta
che le moto che cerca cerca cerca parte
doveva entrare dentro la nelle celle
forza che ci sono dei bagarozzi e gli
scarafaggi
qui c'è una cella aperta però trovano
card e qui insieme vedi il disegno di
qualcuno che l'ha vista scarcerare o la
card
eccolo
[Musica]
ho detto posso passati e presenti a te
quando prendiamo la carta arriva lui
quindi puo essere super veloci tu prendi
la card e io aspetto qua
io vi arriva via life resta sì l'ho
presa ha bisogno se li vicino
sì sì ok mai mattina card eccolo no no
mi ha preso tutto sei riuscito a passare
o non è il solo al card ma la messa vuol
dire che la devi mettere anche tu allora
prendiamo la card e poi scappiamo
dimmiquando 6 prova di la prendiamo
insieme
non mi prega e qui qui e qui in spagna
da bravo ragazzo non sta andando bene
non riusciva a passare al decimo posto
ti aspetto qui beato te io devo
riprendere la carta e devi scappare
quando esci dalla cella comincia a
saltare largo la
tutto a destra tutto
quando ti avvicini vai subito verso la
porta
no ok ragazzi ce l'ho fatta molta
volontà un registro perché ci ho provato
50 volte a scappare la scuola guardia
appoggia l'ho fatto e sono finita 4
laura banco aiutiamo berus te non ha
tempo per uscire ok allora dice mensa
esistono dei latere attento si possono
disattivare ma purtroppo no
facciamo allora
sono stato io
allora forza in mezzo c'è qui andiamo a
uno alla volta è riuscita a sì
non ci credo che ce l'ho fatta ma tocca
me adesso
passerà scherzo per le date un attimo
progettata anche io a non c'è problema
non c'è bisogno di parlare perché
flagella da solo non ci credo che ancora
vivono di fatto
cos'è la o no cosa hai fatto sono andato
avanti
e chiudono bordo alle spalle così sono
riuscito a passarlo certe parole ne
risente
ma come sei bordo qualche parte non lo
so un biglietto ricordato ora
eccolo sta arrivando ecco ti vedo la
giuve del turno ma è tutto dovuto
prenotare non certo propria provincia
ok non trovare la salma cerca di evitare
le parti vertici sono accorto o no e
quindi euro e quindi è troppo bene qui
dietro saltato di tavoli appreso
non c'è una giusta ma dobbiamo capire da
che parte si può scappare no
trova sotto capito dove
si
continuano a rincorrersi però
ok ok ecco di prova tu non ci credo
siamo lì già fatto personale radice di
usare male fa non so se fidarmi eh no
aspetta ma ehi
ma forse bisognava toglierla era una
trappola e ora e c'era anche scritto e
dire che dobbiamo ricominciare da capo
no dai
allora provo io a saltare qui nella
parte ii e iii dei
test aver prezzato
povero vitale non ricominciamo da qui ok
salta pure giochi ma scusami ma c'era
anche scritto usa la trappola
imbrogliato furbi mandiamo ok sono
riuscito a passare
guardiate
siamo io penso che siamo quasi giunti
alla fine vedi allora bisogna scappare
qui è difficilissimo forse non dobbiamo
andare così in fondo dobbiamo provare le
porte che ci sono che
ho capito
poi dobbiamo provare questo
non vedo l'ora di vedere la guardia
espressione allora tu perché chiamare no
io poi pre vero questo che mi raccomando
ai vincoli
sei pronta ma non c'è eccolo come non
c'è
forse perché per ognuno di noi
diversamente
allora aspetta
ok stare ma tiene in considerazione che
ci vuole del tempo
promette tanto ci sarà prima puoi
farcela puoi farcela poi
volete
è stato bellissimo a salvare quella
guardia e ora dice che siamo lì questo
non so cosa sia ma no questo lo fa
uscire ma
devo salire sul treno e ora è su tale
tema libero no
quello fu chi chiede un momento portate
voi che si crei scappare da questa
prigione
diffusissimo vediamo che cosa succede a
me ma mi ha ancora detto che siamo
riusciti a scappare vediamo cosa si
aspetta adesso c'è lui che adesso prende
a martellate
siamo fortuna viviamo scendere dal treno
no aspetta
ce l'ha più fatta
non ce l'abbiamo fatta
si difendono 21
siamo
e non trento da una coscienza ne priva
no ha detto guarda viaggio ci sono delle
coppe
corri corri corri corri vivo cosa
scrivere il budget
più paura che arrivi subito non ci credo
che arrivi la guardiana l'abbiamo
sfracellata mi ci metto anch'io preso il
peggio questi un parco o non ci credo
che ce l'abbiamo fatta
e stato fantastico the screw banche sera
un po paura
è bellissima mi raccomando lasciato
qualcosa si più meraviglia so4 certo se
lirio cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
via
[Musica]